okay
you can take right
okay did not appreciate homicide who
think I started so yeah let further ado
like the first stop is another comment
and we'll talk us about the what vector
is the question we think about
trajectories of oxidation algorithm is
not only the properties of the
stationary points talk is a logic
optimization generalization deep
learning through trajectories of
gradient descent it will start with kind
of a recap or perspective on what the
basic questions are for optimization
generalization deep learning and then I
will kind of state the main argument
that I'm trying to make in this talk and
all the rest of the time will be devoted
in to trying to make the case for this
argument and so at least in supervised
learning when we talk about optimization
we mean fitting training data by
minimizing some objective it's a loss
function and generalization refers to
controlling the gap between our
performance on the training data and on
the test data this could be achieved for
example by adding regularization term to
the objective or a constraint in
classical machine learning the basic
theme it starts off from the fact that
the objectives are convex usually we
choose models and problems such that the
objective will be convex there's usually
one global minimum that's sufficiently
attainable and the choice of algorithm
effects the speed at which you get to
that minimum but no matter what sensible
algorithm you use you will get to the
same solution so the statistical
properties of that solution are
irrelevant to the algorithm generally
speaking in terms of generalization
there's a famous bias-variance tradeoff
which qualitatively speaking states that
if I apply more regularization than the
gap between train and tester decreases
but the training error will go up and I
care about the sum of these two things
the test error hence there's a trade-off
and on the other hand if I make my
regularization weaker then the gap will
open up but the training error will go
down all at all I think it's fairly safe
to say that we have a reasonable
understanding of what goes on here deep
learning the situation is very very
different we allow the objectives to be
non car
and there's not just one global minimum
there are a lot of them and a priori
it's not clear that one could even reach
them efficiently but somehow on typical
problems different variants of gradient
descent seem to reach one of these
minima and we don't really understand
why and for generalization the situation
is even more peculiar we know that least
empirically we know that some global
minima generalize well they have a low
test error but others generalize very
poorly and for some miraculous reason on
typical problems with typical data use
gradient descent or variants thereof you
often get to a solution that generalizes
well and maybe most surprisingly is the
fact that there seems to be no explicit
bias-variance tradeoff peter talked
about this hey we can train huge models
with a small number of examples without
applying any explicit regularization and
we will generalize over all I think most
here would agree that we don't really
have a good understanding of these
questions and that is why we're here
and the argument that I will try and
make today is that maybe the language
that we developed for classical learning
theory is not sufficient for
understanding what goes on in deep
learning and in that case I believe that
a potentially fruitful direction is to
look closely at the course of learning
and that means the trajectories of
gradient descent study what happens
throughout the optimization process try
and make the case for this argument
through deep linear neural networks yeah
that's gonna be the basic theme of the
talk so without further ado let's move
to the actual content the material that
I'll present is based on three papers
one from the last ICML one from this
year's IC LR and another one that's
under review
my esteemed collaborators know Sanjeev
in elad and graduate students Wei who
and you King law and Norah Gullah which
which was an undergrad visited us last
summer so what's a linear neural network
a linear neural network and the learning
jargon is a fully connected neural
network with linear activation
that just means that it's a mapping from
input to output that is linear but it's
parameterised as a sequence of matrix
multiplications so from a
representational perspective it only
realizes linear mappings there's nothing
special about this but in terms of
optimization in generalization this
simple model is highly non-trivial and
it exhibits a lot of behaviors that are
similar to what we see with nonlinear
DBMS and for this reason it's often
viewed as kind of a theoretical
surrogate and a lot of people are
looking into this
including a lot of people here there's
just a sample of papers from last couple
of years what we're gonna start with is
summarize an analysis of the
trajectories of gradient descent or
gradient flow to be exact over linear
nuts and then we're gonna use those
results for analyzing optimization
generalization and along the way we will
see that using our trajectory analysis
allows us to circumvent problems that
one encounters if you try and adopt more
traditional viewpoints a gradient flow
this is a continuous version of gradient
descent this is what you get when you
take the step size to be very very small
it's a differential equation curve in
space and every point your movement is
in the direction that's opposite to the
gradient so gradient descent to these
discrete steps gradient flow is this
continuous curve this thing is useful
because it's continuous and allows you
to use a lot of mathematical machinery
and we will see how these some of the
results that we're gonna derive we're
gonna translate them from gradient flow
to gradient descent so gradient flow is
kind of a theoretical stepping-stone now
let's start talking about the
trajectories of gradient flow over
linear neural Nets so the kind of
objectives that we're interested in have
the following for L is some loss over
linear models this video - loss or cross
entropy or whatever usually it's convex
and this kind of loss immediately
induces an over parameterised objective
over a linear net a fee w1 - W and that
is our objective over a linear net the
value
teni just multiply the matrices by one
another get the end-to-end mapping plug
that into the original loss so you know
L is usually convex fie is highly non
convex here's the definition it has
profound implications but for now it's
just out of nowhere we say that the
weights W 1 2 WN are balanced if the
following equality holds for every j WJ
plus 1 transpose times itself is equal
to WJ WJ transpose where every layer
this is just a definition it as I said
has profound implications the reason why
it's reasonable is because this either
holds exactly or approximately under
fairly common initialization schemes if
you initialize close to 0 then this
thing is almost met if you initialize to
identity just kind of linear resonates
then it's met exactly and what we show
is that gradient flow over linear Nath's
preserves balance nough said if the
weights are it initialized to be
balanced they're gonna stay that way
throughout the entire optimization
trajectory ok gradient flow does not
move arbitrarily in space it follows
certain trajectories and in particular
balanced trajectories if you initialize
in these common ways and this result
allows us to address the following
question
suppose we optimize the linear neural
map with gradient flow and we can ask at
every point in time what the what is the
equivalent linear model
hey we're optimizing over W 1 to W N and
what we ask is what happens to the
end-to-end matrix the one that
represents the entire mapping how does
that thing move in space ok it does not
follow gradient flow over L over the
loss because we're not running gradient
flow over the loss we are over
parameterizing with a linear neural net
and runni gradient flow on that so how
does this thing move in space and the
result that we show using the balance
this property is the following if the
weights are balanced at initial
then the end-to-end matrix follows what
we call the end-to-end dynamics it's
what's written here ignore this blue
term you just get gradient flow and to
add matrix moves according to the
gradient with a minus sign that just
means to take a matrix arrange it in
this vector if you don't have the blue
term it's meaningless blue term is what
manifests the fact that we used a linear
neural net this thing is a
pre-conditioner it's a PSD matrix it has
actually a closed form expression here
it is please don't try and parse this
I'm just showing you to get a sense that
it's not that complicated this is the
closed form expression for the
pre-conditioner intuitively what this
pre-conditioner does is it promotes
movement in the directions that you've
already taken and what do I mean by that
the pre-conditioner depends on the
end-to-end matrix and those singular
directions that have a large singular
value here those are the ones these
directions are the ones where the
gradient is going to be stretched more
significantly so if I start off near
zero I wander somewhere in space I
reached a point those directions were
I've traveled a long distance the
gradient there is going to be pushed
more significantly yeah that's kind of
an intuitive way to describe what goes
on here it's possible to formalize this
bottom line is that if we had a linear
model and we add redundant linear layers
we turn this into a linear network we
are implicitly inducing a
pre-conditioner okay that promotes
movement and directions already taken
all of the results we're going to derive
for optimization generalization rely on
this theorem
all right let's now move to optimization
this is gonna be about half the time
I'll try to focus more on generalization
because that's a newer stuff yeah
the results for that too like we can
talk about actually show some of that
where it's approximately bounced I'll
get to that
thanks okay so before we talk about
utilizing our trajectory analysis for
optimization let's say word about the
alternative classic approach one of the
most prominent approaches for analyzing
optimization in learning nowadays is to
look at the geometry specifically
characterize the curvature the geometry
of critical points have different types
of critical points I could have a local
minimum that's good the objective is
close to the global minimum I could have
a local minimum that's bad the objective
is much worse I could have a saddle with
a negative curvature direction so
there's kind of directions of
significant descent or I could have a
non strict saddle so it's very flat yet
to walk significant distance to start
the descent formally fashion here does
not have negative vacant values okay and
a result that was shown yes
couple years ago by different groups and
different flavors many of them sitting
here basically if you sweep away a lot
of the details it states the following
if there are no bad local minima all
right so you don't have any points like
this and there are no non strict saddles
you don't have any points like this then
gradient descent will eventually reach
global minimum basically it means that
it's not gonna get stuck in strict
saddle points this is very the fairly
encouraging you can hope to maybe show
convergence to global optimum just by
looking at the geometry of critical
points without considering the interplay
between the model and algorithm and
things like that and indeed there have
been many works that have focused on
establishing these properties no bad
local minima and no non strict saddles
and you could maybe hope that maybe it's
possible to prove convergence to global
optimum for deep linear nets using this
approach but it turns out that this kind
of approach hits a wall right at the
set because if you're interested in deep
models three or more layer models then
property two is just flat-out false it's
not true that there are no non-straight
saddles for example when all the weights
are zero all the second derivatives are
going to be zero and there you go
there's a non spring set so you can't
really hope to use this kind of approach
as is we're gonna do is leverage our
trajectory analysis so this is the
pre-conditioner these are the dynamics
that we derived i didn't show you this
but it's pretty easy to see that if the
end-to-end matrix is full rank then the
free conditioner is positive definite
meaning it's not going to kill this
gradient and so the descent is going to
continue the loss is gonna decrease
until one of two things happen either
the gradient is zero okay in that case
obviously there's no movement or maybe
the gradient is not 0 but the
pre-conditioner killed it and that's
only possible the end-to-end matrix was
singular usually the loss L is convex so
reaching 0 gradient means that you have
reached the global minimum so we get the
following corollary for gradient flow if
the loss is convex and I initialized the
linear net such that the loss at
initialization is better than the loss
of any singular matrix so by going down
I'm never going to hit singularity
that's condition 1 condition 2 is that
the weights are balanced under these two
conditions gradient flow will eventually
converge to global minimum this is a de
Convergys result for gradient flow under
two assumptions on initialization
there's no notion of computational
efficiency obviously because this is a
continuous optimization practice we're
interested we are interested in
computational efficiency
what we do is translate this result from
gradient flow to gradient descent this
is the corollary for gradient flow I
will now wiggle a little bit with these
conditions I'll just write them
differently I'm not gonna change them
instead of write up saying that I want
the loss to be better than the loss of
any singular matrix I'll say that I want
it to be better than the loss of any
matrix with a zero singular value
exactly the same thing let's first plug
in the definition that's the definition
of balance miss now instead of writing
that these two things are equal I'll
just write that the norm of their
difference is zero
then change anything now we're gonna
slightly modify this and get a theorem
for gradient descent ok I'm just gonna
show you what we prove I'm not gonna so
first of all the result for gradient
descent we proved it for l2 loss it's
possible to extend it to any strongly
convex foster and these two conditions
we kind of defined discrete versions of
them instead of requiring that the loss
be better than the loss of any matrix
with the zero singular value I'll
require a little bit more I wanted to be
better than the loss of any matrix in
the singular value that smaller the
other hand instead of requiring perfect
balance these norms to be zero I will
allow them to be small not X it don't
have to be zero okay smaller than
something that scales like C square
under these two conditions gradient
descent with a step size that scales
like C to the fourth gives you linear
rate convergence exponentially fast
convergence loss iteration T scales like
e to the minus constant times T so we
have here a result for linear rate
convergence of gradient descent over
arbitrarily deep models under two
assumptions on initialization what can
we say about these assumptions so first
of all we know that in some sense
they're both necessary meaning that you
can't just erase one of these conditions
and hope that the theorem will hold
because it does not hold it's easy to
come up with counter example
if you race any one of them then I can
easily come up with an example where
convergence is gonna fail or even
diverge so you can't just remove them
you can maybe weaken them the second
thing we show is that for the case of
output dimension 1 if you use a random
initialization that's similar to what
people usually use but not exactly
without getting into the details we call
this random balanced initialization if
you use this thing then with constant
probability both of the conditions are
met and you get linear rate convergence
the global minimum by constant I don't
just second I don't mean some positive
constant I mean 0.25 or close to 0.5 so
use this initialization no assumptions
at all with probability close to 0.5 you
get linear rate convergence the global
optimum the second so what we have here
is a result that shows efficient
convergence of gradient descent on a
compact model one that you could
actually fit in your computer and that
model is allowed to have three or more
layers an arbitrary number of layers ok
to my knowledge this is the most general
guarantee to date of this particular
kind what it means well it's a condition
of how good your loss at initialization
is ok you need to be slightly better
than matrices that are almost singular
ok it's some condition on the question
of how reasonable this is then this is
supposed to be the answer the constant
probability that 0.25 is good so you
need to be better than chance then the
origin becomes 0.5 times something to
the minus n that's correct to the minus
output dimension that positive
probability
there's still a positive constant
probability but it depends on the output
dimension in an exponentially bad way so
it's not that impressive for higher
output dimension even for a per to
mention one to my knowledge there are no
results no it's just the end to end it's
just in the end to end space there's no
this theorem if well if the output
dimension is one then that can never
happen but this theorem is not these
conditions are not gonna be met if you
have this bottleneck layer that's
narrower than the input analysis yeah
I'm trying to kind of circumvent some of
the okay this was possible thanks to our
trajectory analysis just looking at the
geometry kind of a classic approach
would not have given us this result and
what we're gonna see now is something I
think that is potentially more
interesting in tests even more to the
importance of trajectories and that's
the effect of depth on optimization the
classical view is that convex
optimization is much easier than on
convex and optimizing a linear model is
easier than optimizing a deep net
because this gives you a non convex
objective this gives you a linear one
that's the classical view and what we're
gonna see is that through our trajectory
analysis we're gonna see that this is
not always the case sometimes it's
easier to optimize these things than it
is to optimize so I won't get into too
many details kind of work because they
want to get the generalization part I'll
just state the result hey this is our
end to end dynamics in the discrete
version so there's discrete updates
here's our pre-conditioner and what we
show is the following for any P greater
than two there exist setting was where
the loss is the LP loss so it's based on
the P norm to the power of P of the
difference between true label and
production
that's a convex loss there exist cases
with this loss where the end-to-end
dynamics reach the global minimum much
much faster than gradient descent so
what this means is that there exist
cases where I could run gradient descent
over a linear model optimizing convex
objective or on the other hand do
something crazy which is to replace the
linear model by a deep linear network
and we run gradient descent on that the
latter option would give me much faster
convergence there exist such cases so
this is non-intuitive it goes against
the conventional wisdom but it might not
be practical the fact that there exist
such cases doesn't mean that we
encounter them in practice the probe
here cooks some certain data set that
makes this happen it might be possible
to mock we didn't invest too much
thought into that but it's what we show
this for fix no it's not met it's
critical the fact that it be greater
than 2 and there's the intuitive
explanations for why because you need
the loss to be very flat around the
minimum and steeper around the edges we
kind of take advantage of that I'm
trying not to get into all these details
but it's not true for people still so
the classical explanations for
acceleration based
differential equations is that in
gradient flow you get a first-order in
the accelerated gradient yeah so by
analogy here if you are just using
gradient descent and then let's say you
over parametrize message is two layers
when you have that balance conditions
you can eliminate and get a second
equation so it's related to momentum
which is related to second-order there
is a relation some difficulties as to
whether you're saying you can construct
examples for the verse of the situation
where this is generic because over
privatization would guess and please the
order of the differential equation I
don't think this is I know it's not true
for P equals two or less for P greater
than two actually every setting we tried
experimentally this did happen I don't
think this is generic I think you could
maybe well I could come up with data
sets worth what would happen maybe in a
random data set it will but we didn't we
don't have that kind of result to get a
sense of how realistic this is how
common this situation is in practice we
run experiments ran a lot of them I'll
just show you the basic one this is a
regression problem from UCI machine
learning repository we use out for loss
because we need P greater than two and
this is what you get where you compare a
one layer model in blue that's a convex
loss versus a two layer model and a
three layer model these are non convex
objectives and you see that the loss
decrease is much faster this is long
scale so in this particular case adding
depth speeds up gradient descent even
without any gain and expressiveness and
despite the fact that it introduces non
convexity every single setting we tried
with L for loss or L or P gradient to
this happened this also happened with
non linear models and I recently heard
that someone took this idea and applied
it to more large-scale settings
that's a great question yeah so and it
is higher but just to make that point
in this particular case this is output
dimension 1 and every layer is just a
scalar so it's almost the same this is
like a thousand parameters this is seven
thousand one this is thousand two so
even if you divide by the number of
parameters it's it okay let's move to
the new stuff generalization we're gonna
look at a setting where generalization
carries a very concrete meaning and that
is matrix completion it's a classic
problem I get a subset of entries from
some unknown matrix and I want to
complete the entries that I haven't seen
has a lot of practical applications as
we know and this can be seen as a
supervised learning problem I can think
of any entry that I observe as a
training example and every entry that I
did not observe as a test example and
generalization means recovering the
testings or being accurate on the test
examples obviously you need to assume
something about the grant truth matrix
otherwise you can't do anything and the
baseline assumption is that the grant
truth matrix is low rank and there's a
classic algorithm now it's classic by
Ben and Candice and essentially what it
states is the following if I look at the
set of matrices that agree with the
observed entries and from this set I
choose the one with minimal nuclear norm
nuclear norms the sum of singular values
that's a convex program then under
certain technical assumptions let's put
them aside because they are in some
sense rare if I have enough observed
entries then I will get perfect recovery
so a convex program will give me perfect
recovery if I have sufficiently many
entries which is the minimal number that
needed times some logarithmic factor and
for this reason this matrix completion
problem is often regarded to be solved
we're gonna see is that this in practice
requirement for sufficiently many
observations makes a difference and
there are cases
where other algorithms do a much better
job than nuclear norm minimization yeah
we'll see that what we're focused on is
the use of linear Nets for doing matrix
completion let's start with a two-layer
case because that's already classic
algorithm in that case I parameterize
the grant truth has a product of two
matrices w1 times w2 I can constrain the
shared dimension and thereby force a
low-rank or I could not do so in any
case this algorithm is called matrix
factorization hey running like
optimizing over this parameter ization
and there's an empirical phenomenon that
I think is fairly known but not these
group I guess but the spotlight on this
thing
and that is that if you run gradient
descent over this parameter is a ssin
with a small step size an initialization
close to zero then even if I didn't
constrain the rank a low rank matrix is
going to be found matrix factorization
does a good job in recovering low rank
matrices and doing matrix completion
there is some implicit regularization at
play and the conjecture that they made
is that in this case gradient descent
with small step size and initialization
close to zero over this matrix
factorization implicitly realizes the
classic convex algorithm implicitly it
finds the minimal nuclear norm solution
and they actually prove this for a
certain specific setting so what we
tried to do is build on this great work
and look at what happens when you have n
layers not just two in this case I
parameterize the grand truth as a
product of n matrices right and we call
this unsurprisingly
deep matrix factorization okay and the
first thing we did was run an experiment
we ran matrix completion and compared
deep matrix factorizations to shallow
once when the step size gets smaller and
the initialization becomes closer to
zero so this is what you see here we're
completing a matrix here
this is depth to depth 3 and f4 x axis
here that's the standard deviation of
initialization you can see what happens
when it gets smaller there are actually
two curves here they're almost one on
top of the other but they correspond to
different learning rates so you can see
what happens when that gets smaller and
in this case depths three and four
significantly outperform depth two in
this case depth enhanced the implicit
regularization towards low rank and what
we were interested in is trying to
theoretically analyze this phenomenal
the first direction that we went to is
to follow great footsteps of others
okay the conjecture that was made by
goodness Eckert albeit grouping TTI is
that the implicit regularization with
depth two boils down to minimizing
nuclear norm she's a surrogate of rank
we initially thought is that maybe
because we see that deeper models give
you a low rank solution then maybe with
a deeper Network there's some other norm
or quasi norm that's being minimized
which is closer to rank the nuclear norm
is here's the most straightforward
example Shatan p quasi norms the second
p quasi norm of a matrix is the sum of
the singular values to the power of P
okay for P equals 1 this is exactly
nuclear norm
that's what according to the conjecture
corresponds to depth 2 and 4 be smaller
than 1
this is a quasi norm and it's actually
closer to rank the nuclear normals so
what we initially thought is that when I
add depth I am taking P from being 1 to
being smaller hey that's what we
initially hope to show but things did
not exactly pan out as we planned them
to and which often happens the first
result we ended up proving is that in
the particular case we're going to
secure it out prove their conjecture
nuclear norm is being minimized not just
with depth 2 but with any depth all of
the depths minimize nuclear norm and we
also show that it there are certain
instances of this setting we're
minimizing nuclear norm means that you
are provably not minimizing any Shatan
quasi norm not even locally so this
means that what we hope to show that the
implicit regularization with depth
is equivalent to Shatan quasi nor
minimization or maybe even locally
that's not the case we know for a fact
that this is not true the other hand if
you kind of adopt the lens of gonna
Sakura doll then maybe you end up with a
different conjecture and that is that
all the depths actually minimize nuclear
note so then we came up with kind of
maybe this direction but this does not
comply with our experiments our
experiments show that depth gives you
closer approximation of rank so what's
going on here okay so what we did next
is kind of more careful experimentation
of this nuclear nor minimization idea we
this is the setting of completing a rank
five hundred by hundred matrix and we
start with the case where you observe a
lot of entries okay so one hundred by
hundred rank five matrix so you need
about a thousand there are a thousand
degrees of freedom but we use five
thousand observed entries here we
compare nuclear nor minimization to
linear nets of different dusts this is
the reconstruction air that's the
nuclear norm of the final solution and
this is the effective rank Peter
mentioned you just think of this as rank
some continuous approximation and in
this case because there are a lot of
observed entries minimizing the nuclear
norm indeed gives you an almost perfect
reconstruction air so it finds the grant
truth right the nuclear norm is 221 any
effective rank is five which exactly
complies with the rank of the ground
truth linear Nets in this case also give
you a very good reconstruction not as
good but almost perfect as well so
obviously they found the same matrix so
the nuclear norms are going to be the
same and so are the ranks so in this
case there is a correspondence these
linear Nets of all depths indeed
minimize the nuclear norm okay but
nuclear norm here minimizing nuclear
norm finds the grant truth so we can't
really distinguish between nuclear nor
minimization and maybe there's another
implicit regularization that pushes
these models to low rank you would get
to the same matrix so on the way I would
also minimize nuclear norm but that
might not be the driving force and to
get a more kind of fair comparison
look at a setting with a smaller number
of entries and here nuclear nor
minimization does not give you a very
good reconstruction the default is point
eight this is point one the nuclear own
that's found is to ten it's lower than
before but the rank is higher so by
focusing on nuclear nor minimization
that kind of missed the low rank it got
in ranked nine and in this case linear
Nets give you better reconstruction
error especially depths three and four
and they give you a lower rank here it's
like almost perfect reconstruction the
norm is higher so they seem to give up
on the nuclear nor minimization in favor
of lowering the rank just second so in
this case we can interpret this as a
discrepancy and this happened in every
setting we looked at where the nuclear
norm does a poor job in reconstructing
all these without any noise any kind of
noise because when you have that matrix
it is presumably much more at least
intuitively more sensitive to well the
idea is that they find a lower rank
solution you can argue if that's
accurate or not with respect to what you
want to recover but we didn't we didn't
play with these settings in this
experiment no but what we are kind of
saying here is that sometimes it's
nuclear on that's being minimized
sometimes it's something else
maybe there's this kind of by modality
where after some threshold it becomes
this norm afterwards it's that I know
it's no shot it's no shot and cause I
know that I know but maybe it's
something else and the kind of
conclusion we reached is that maybe it's
just not possible to capture everything
that's going on with a single norm or
quasi noise and that kind of led us to
resort to move back to our trajectories
and see if we can show some
using that kind of dynamical analysis so
this is our implicit pre-conditioner
here I'm marking in the green that's the
end-to-end matrix and what we're gonna
look at is what happens to the singular
values of this end-to-end matrix we
would like to somehow show that it fine
there's a kind of implicit tendency
towards low rank meaning that the
singular values the gaps are opened
between the singular values that's kind
of what we were hoping to show and
actually that's that is what we
discovered Sigma are here these are the
singular values of the end-to-end matrix
and you are V R these are the
corresponding left and right singular
vectors the result that we derived for
the dynamics of the singular values is
what's written here ignore this Brown
turn for a second see that the movement
of a singular value is just minus the
projection of the gradient on to the
corresponding singular component the
only place where depth n comes into play
in this equation is in these factors if
N equals one then these factors reduce
to 1 they disappear and all you get is
this projection that's what governs the
dynamics of singular values if I start
introducing depth then these factors
come into play
and while these constants don't make any
difference because I can absorb them
into the learning rate these
coefficients do make a difference
what a singular value is small then this
coefficient attenuates the movement it
makes it move much much slower on the
other hand if a singular value is large
that it's movement enhances it moves
much much faster and the larger end is
the greater the power is here so the
more significant the effect is and this
is what happens when you optimize a
linear net over any loss and suppose
you're optimizing some underdetermined
loss like in matrix completion and you
initialize close to zero then what we
would expect is that when to think of
their values are small after
initialization they're barely going to
move and then each singular value once
it reaches a certain threshold it'll
start moving rapidly shoot up and that
ultimately will give you a low rank
solution because most of the singular
who's stayed close to zero and only a
small number of them shot up and this is
what we observed in every experiment
that we ran okay this is matrix
completion this is for depth one this is
our singular values move there's no
implicit regularization this is depth
one okay in the unobserved entries
you're not learning any and all the sinc
of their values move together you don't
get a little rank solution this is what
happens when you add a layer so the
smaller secular values move much less
and these values leading components once
they become larger than some threshold
they start moving much faster and you
get something that's closer to low rank
and indeed the reconstruction error is
much lower if I add another layer then
this becomes even more significant and
the smaller ones barely move at all they
get a very low rank solution and this
gives me an almost perfect
reconstruction so this is kind of a
miracle illustration the intuition and
there's kind of we also characterized
its movement as well I'm just not talked
about it but there is a non-trivial
dependency there yeah
it's not like there's a complete
decoupling so this kind of analysis in
general it's not as elegant as saying
that some norm is being minimized
obviously usually in classical learning
theory when we regularize we use some
norm so it's natural to think that maybe
deep Nets implicitly do this it would
obviously be a much better outcome than
having a dynamical analysis but what I
am arguing is that there's no reason to
believe that that it's possible okay the
fact that we're explicitly regularizing
what norms does not mean that the
implicit regularization with deep Nets
does something similar it could be
different and look at it the
trajectories is a way to somehow take
into account
the relevant details for this special
case super simple just second of one
observed entry we can actually give
closed-form expressions for the
dependencies a different sink of their
values we know that for depth one the
relationship is linear so if once
together value gets larger the other one
can grow linearly grows linearly with it
for depth two it's polynomial so if this
singular value grows this one could grow
like square root and things like that
and with higher depths it becomes
asymptotic so if this singular value
could be huge this one would still not
pass some threshold over all we see here
that depth leads to larger gaps between
singular values which means lower rank
iteration this is the course of learning
why is it not an integer all right so
let's conclude so recap is the main
argument or position that I'm making is
that understanding optimization
generalization deep learning might not
be possible through the language that we
developed for classical learning and in
that case it might be beneficial to
analyze the trajectories of gradient
descent that's the entire course of
learning the dynamics of what goes on
there
we try and make the case through deep
linear neural maths we analyze the
trajectories and show that depth induces
a pre-conditioner that promotes movement
directions already taken we use this for
optimization we derived a guarantee of
efficient convergence to global minimum
which shows you fast convergence over an
arbitrarily deep model that's compact
and can fit in your computer this is the
most general guarantee of that kind the
nominee we're up and more surprisingly
we saw them in this case depth can
actually accelerate convergence even
though it doesn't give you anything in
terms of expressiveness and despite the
fact that it introduces non convexity
and for generalization our trajectories
show that depth enhances an implicit
regularization towards low rank which
for problems such as matrix completion
amounts to better generalization okay
and just a word about the future so
we've talked about linear nets which are
nice
a great theoretical tool but at the end
of the day these are not the models that
we usually run practice we're interested
in nonlinear nuts and it's difficult to
analyze nonlinear nets with value and
things like that it's not analytical but
there's another type of nonlinear neural
nets which I believe are much more a
reach and we saw that linear neural Nets
they correspond to matrix factorizations
and in the kind of language of
decompositions of multi-dimensional
arrays this could be plotted as this
chain every node here corresponds to a
matrix parameter and this graphical
language allows us to describe not just
matrix factorizations but tensor
factorizations as well factorizations of
high dimensional arrays and there are
different topologies like trees and
trains and things like that and what
colleagues and I may be University have
shown few years back is that just like
matrix factorizations correspond to
linear Nets tensor factorizations
correspond to arithmetic nests
arithmetic nets are nonlinear models ok
so if you have a tree factorization that
corresponds to a convolutional nets and
a train factorization corresponds to a
recurrent net these networks have a
structure that is very or it's actually
identical to practical models that
people use but there's one difference
and that is that their arithmetic ok the
nonlinearities are only based on
products these are kind of polynomial
networks so they're much more algebraic
in nature but they're not exactly the
type of models that usually people use
but nonetheless they do work well in
practice for example on so far they
reach over 90% and they are more
amenable to theoretical analysis so I
believe these kind of models could be
the next step beyond linear nets and we
actually started doing this and analyzed
the trajectories and they some of the
results for linear Nets transfer to
these models as well like the notion of
balance 'no sand things like that so i
hope that maybe in the near future we'll
have some results on the trajectories of
these models may be able to say more
about optimization and generalization
for a nonlinear model it's not exactly
what most people use but it does work
well in track
[Applause]
so our question regarding your main I
bought this is so it seems to me like
you're associating to every point in the
invasion derive the same results by a
global structure in a global Romanian
structure instead of great great
question that's it relates the mirror
descent and stuff that's sound going on
going bad at offline there is something
you can describe what what did I do
I took a model a linear net and I
replaced that by an equivalent algorithm
I said that this linear Nets gradient
descent over the linear net can be
thought of as some other algorithm over
a linear model turns out that I could
even do more it's the equivalent to
gradient descent over a linear model but
with an underlying metric that's
different
[Applause]
so our our next speaker is Misha and who
come talk to us